porque eu estou aqui hoje muitas pessoas
falam comigo assim é não só nos
comentários não só que no youtube e nas
redes sociais tal mas pessoalmente o que
eu acho muito mais sério quando a pessoa
fala com ele pessoalmente e quando fala
assim eu quero falar contigo ela aí a
pessoa fala é uma coisa agora falou
assim ah quer falar contigo fala isso
não tem que ser pessoalmente seja que
foi que eu fiz que eu me lembre se foi
uma pessoa muito legal e educado esses
dias o que foi que eu fiz aqui eu paulo
[ __ ] merda alguma coisa errada eu fiz e
começa a procurar um erro quando você
não fez isso tudo só porque a pessoa
queria falar que queria falar
pessoalmente conversar na coisa fica
pesado se for pessoalmente pessoalmente
é mais forte e tem muita coisa assim que
pessoalmente também não é forte o jantar
só quer jantar com você
vamos jantar só não tem que ser
pessoalmente hora em que você não tem
como comer transporte sabe mandar foto
da comida solange a tela não dá mas
pessoalmente é [ __ ] aí falei muito meu
deus eu tenho 82 mas muita gente
pessoalmente me fala sobre vídeos no
youtube cara eu quero ser o youtube
estou começando no canal me ensine o
grande lance é o que é isso que me sinto
ancião cada pessoa pede pra ensinar
ensina a fazer vir do youtube o grande
mestre o honorável ansião e muita gente
pessoalmente fala-se muito muito
obrigado cara você está aqui fazer um
show na nossa cidade tira foto com minha
filha a minha filha é o youtube tem como
você dá alguma dica pra e cobriu até
dois dias com as pessoas assim quando eu
ou não mas eu não tenho como ficar
falando de pessoa por pessoa como fai é
muito legal esse negócio de fazer coisas
na internet conteúdo da internet ganhar
dinheiro na internet viver de internet é
muito mais do que você é seu próprio
patrão muita gente ver minha vida e fala
[ __ ] e deve ser muito mas o uhuu
mostrar que minha vida como era antes de
ser famoso e depois é famoso e escovando
os dentes seu famoso bando dentro eu
vejo alguém comendo alguma coisa antes e
famoso ainda um pouquinho a começar
porque só acolherá dinha não dou não eu
vejo alguém comer alguma coisa depois do
famoso e ainda ser ruim dá um pouquinho
a começar porque só acolherá a linha não
eu comer alguma coisa antes de ser
famoso
tá bom
e aí está um pouquinho aí último aipa
[ __ ] que pariu
ela sabe pedir a volta de marcão ou seja
mesma por mesma merda mesma coisa acabou
não eu lógico tem coisas que mudar não
vou ficar quieto ligá-la é humildade
humildade pois agora tem a chance de
viajar pelo mundo conhecer o mundo as
outras línguas antigamente ou errado é
só português a falar nós vai nós foi
agora o time espanhol é ruim inglês eu
tenho tantos liga variedades pá eu
conheci meus ídolo conhecer o tom
cavalcante quarto cavalcante tirulipa
que agora se tornou milan santana
conhecido 11 jan ansa o se hoje de
conhecer o nosso tanque eu falei a ele
lança também incluem isso não seus de ir
luto bom para a irlanda vai ter festa
hoje ele falou não vão na conam a esse
pente com fazerem um led a propor falei
moça não pode ficar fazendo festa até
tarde aqui que o pessoal de manhãzinha
vai trabalhar respondeu quando eles
estão indo pra amanhã
a gente faz amor gostoso de novo negócio
de amor também gosta da escola daí muita
coisa boa conheci por neymar ganso
neymar e marquinhos para esse negócio
aqui nessa luta conversando comigo em pé
o fã 160 o número de quebrar todo jeito
acham tão fraca muito magro mas muita
gente boa demais para as pessoas que
conheci bicho eu fui da qualidade de
vida para minha família qualidade boa
por minha mãe mora na casa mais legal
ajudar pessoas também como foi ontem lá
no interesse no negócio de fraldas
geriátricas velho que eu estava
precisando rose d'or falei quente que eu
falei 12g que fala vem eu falei eu vou
falar velho eu vou fazer assim o placar
o riba é um carro
lá o um carro morreu amigo e lady of a
madman ele falar que já estava velho
ficou velho na minha cabeça não consigo
me acostumar com a palavra bunda ajudou
o dose entre 300 e tantos mil reais que
a gente conseguiu que o negócio lembra
de um negócio pp vocês ajudaram a
instituição música no hospital
tudo com vocês negócio influência e
eleger o cara mais influente do brasil
em 2017 o que meu deus como isso nem
acabou 2017 muita coisa pode acontecer
até dezembro eu já sou o cara mais
influente do que imaginei essa votação
decidiram pensando [ __ ] botar aqui
[ __ ] esse aqui é bom mas de tanto
sozinho de outro menino já fez a negócio
karaiskaki do fazendeiro que entrar nas
pessoas sobre esse vi é pablo pablo na
turma dos cartões que botei deveria
botar esse jornalista aqui como das
pessoas
oi eu não sei o que vai deixar um
pouquinho assim se diminuiu a vontade é
quem tem que ser assim estou eu como o
cara mais influente do brasil em 2016
mas como pode isso aconteceu as pessoas
perguntam olha vou dizer foi da hora
para outra não eu nasci em bom jesus no
piauí carregava caminhão garçom eu me
inscrevi no curso técnico que tinha pra
ver se eu conseguia sei lá meu deus
trabalhar com o computador campo costuma
mexer com computador e aí eu fui
estagiário assim nesse negócio está já
houve pessoas que fazem o vídeo quis
fazer vídeo assim também mesmo senhor
fala pra mim alimentos o corte queria
fazer vídeos igual simplesmente assim do
nada ou assistir e eu gostei falei vou
fazer isso é assim eu comecei a fazer
vídeo está respondendo às perguntas das
pessoas que me pergunta o endereço como
fui esse negócio começar a fazer vídeo
não pode responder essa pergunta tão
grande que a mesma coisa que você
perguntar para ivete sangalo como foi
ivete como foi quando a gente esse
negócio de começar a contar como foi
assim foi do nada foi como foi quando a
gente olha quem vai gostar de ficar
respondendo à pergunta de terras por
essa pergunta já um milhão de vezes você
deve estar estranhando também porque eu
me comparei com a ivete sangalo não tem
nada a ver a carreira sensacional e eu
tenho vergonha pelo menu corpo parece
grávida de gêmeos
vinte e sete meses e eu fui caro fui
fazendo os vídeos foi fazendo um erro e
matava aula para fazer não
a aula nem usei drogas vale lembrar que
eu fazia tudo isso me matava quando ele
olhar 3 light no vídeo aos mas são três
pessoas que gosta se a terra deslizou
pensava canalha tem que parar de fazer
que está dando certo em gostando eu
parei de fazer pois eu crie outro canal
a lei de fazer também não tava sabe
aquelas coisas eu fiz um aparelho
chamado alô voto replantando o canal
explodiu e aí foi hackeado excluiu falei
meu deus é a vida a vida quer mesmo que
o venda cremosinho larga de moça [ __ ]
na hora de vir mas aí eu voltei com mais
vontade para fazer baby you tube e gás e
eu fui vendo que estava errado que não
dá pra fazer e fui tirando foi botando
ea e patrão lá e se o pool seu canal
estourou tv essa lesão foi só vi na
plaquinha e tome placa a chegou a hora
que acabou weiwei em toda assim aí sendo
a ifá e oscar a e dancei paródia um
monte de coisa e o mais importante pra
mim de verdade mais importante para mim
do fundo do coração o carinho do público
você pode falar senão o dinheiro a
lógica é muito sensacional cara você
fazer alguma coisa e além de você fazer
e teve os as pessoas gostarem de você e
isso é bom de verdade assim a senhorinha
no show todas as senhorinhas venha falar
comigo sim um carinho e um abraço tão de
verdade assim não é tipo a eles em mim
no meu neto god assim vou tirar foto com
ele causa de é não cair o bicho que é
isso é massa calma que eu vou falar mas
qual faz com que eu fiz de diferente
assim para poder dar sempre o melhor de
tudo é não desistir é muito clichê falar
isso é a não desista dos seus sonhos eu
pareço otimismo falando aí não desista
do seu pc como fala inglês para tentar
imitar não desista dos seus sonhos mas é
verdade por que por que cargas de
verdade foi um dos 34 anos da certas
coisas foi muito vídeo vai 300 mil 150 e
outubro não era como é hoje que todo
mundo tem um amigo que tem meio milhão
de escrituário tem um amigo faz um
produto tem 100 mil inscritos não tinha
não existia amigos com tantos inscritos
não tinha amigo com mil inscritos quem
tinha 10 mil inscritos a maioria se
achava o dono do youtube doente que
sozinha se moedas coisa mesmo que eu fui
mais eu fazia humor eu procurei saber
mais sobre o mundo e percussão doidim
que faz
a internet é o do dinheiro até 20 e
tantos milhões de inscritas na sorte é
jô deixou estudei o mundo foi com a
universidade ou não mas tudo que eu
podia achar pela internet eu fui no
pesquisando sobre palco sobre os
comediantes assim quem fazia humor que
eu conhecia famoso no famoso tentar
chegar e perguntar assim como ele fazia
como ele criava tentei fazer stand-up em
bairros um show no bar ao vivo aqui em
são paulo onde uma casa já bem conhecida
de de comediantes na prova balbi eu fui
lá e fiz cara foi uma merda mas foi uma
experiência que eu falei cara ai tônus
feito falar da [ __ ] para aprender como
não é fácil a vida tão cara pesquisa
estuda sério vai pra cima engole cinemas
os textos que você vê na internet foi
isso que eu fiz um golo e mesmo as
coisas e é por isso que estou fazendo
esse vídeo eu pedi muita ajuda eu pedi
muita informação só que o caminho pra
mim foi muito longa muito longo de mais
de maio foi muito estresse foi muito
hoje está tudo bem graças a deus está
tudo certo minha vida mas o caminho que
eu fiz eu eu sério muitas vezes eu falei
cara de verdade não consigo passar disso
eu cheguei meu ápice não consigo passar
isso e é por isso que estou fazendo e
cívica acredito que a educação é o
melhor jeito de alguém mudar de vida
muita gente me encontra na rua muita
gente encontra no show muita gente fala
cara eu quero ser o youtube mas eu não
consigo eu tenho sou time do sul travado
eu não sei fazer piada não sei fazer
parodi isso e aquilo e eu tenho vontade
de ensinar ao mesmo tempo penso quem sou
eu pra ensinar alguma coisa para alguém
entendeu eu lembro da minha vida da
minha história da minha carreira eu sei
que eu não sou a única história tem
várias pessoas como eu hoje tentando sua
vida possa sair de casa e passam paulo
para brasília no pra selar a saída até
mesmo do interior e na capital do seu
próprio estado será em aracaju e no pa
salvador ba manaus am tentar a vida com
um celular tenta a vida se alguém na
vida e que me deu certo eu posso passar
isso para vocês assim então se você tem
algum canal no youtube seja de games
seja de maquiagem seja de curiosidade de
um homem é paródia esquete essas coisas
bolinar a qualquer coisa ou até mesmo
não tem canal no youtube não quer fazer
por dominar quero fazer com o instagram
caros fazer alguma coisa que eu cresci
no instagram ou no facebook ou em algum
lugar no twitter para levar minha vida
com internet e vi
de internet foi por isso que esse vídeo
mas para inspirar você pra você que quer
continuar fazendo a mostrar a vocês que
não é questão de sorte que não é a meu
deus é iluminado é um dom que a pessoa
tem não eu fui muito atrás para aprender
e isso vai ser muito cara na minha
cabeça para poder conseguir a ideia
aquela coisa pra poder ou sei lá
bom aí eu vou trazer algumas coisas no
canal aqui pra ajudar você que quer
fazer conteúdo na internet e viver disso
ganhar dinheiro com isso inclusive
segunda feira agora é de 25 eu vou
lançar outro vídeo no canal contando
algumas coisas que eu fiz meu canal
crescer como foi que eu fiz pra crescer
nos nas redes sociais também pra você
que tem esse sonho uma quero sê agora
youtube quero trabalhar com um facebook
com o instagram no dia 28 tava fazer uma
lá e vi aqui no youtube contando muita
coisa pra vocês também sobre um projeto
novo que está fazendo aí que é um curso
online você quer trabalhar com internet
caso lembrando que não é para falar eu
quero acompanhar e não você vai fazer
esse curso online quem quer trabalhar
com isso eu conheço muita gente é meio
barata tonta que trabalhar com isso é
meio barato então eu vou contar um
discurso tipo tudo exatamente tudo que
aqui eu contei por alto nem as coisas
que eu fiz alguma coisa e tal mas nesse
curso vou contar exatamente tudo o que
eu fiz e o que você também deveria fazer
um curso de como ficar famoso na
internet como bater sucesso no youtube
como bombar o seu canal não é um curso
que eu vou mostrar tudo o que eu fiz pro
meu canal você desse jeito
lembrando você quiser a perder tempo com
isso caso você não queira trabalhar com
internet nem precisa saber tá com essa
coisa pra quem quer viver disso mesmo tá
se você não quer ver disse 'você só
acompanhamos de guardas parole board um
novo olha com média pode ficar tranquilo
que amanhã em vídeo normal de um normal
como sempre você só os vídeos mais aqui
no canal não fique de olho na segunda
feira quem quer viver disso internet
youtube quer que você comente aqui
embaixo no youtube é que você queria
saber sobre o assunto que você quer
saber sobre meu canal sobre paródia
sobre humor sobre meus vídeos sobre como
eu faço isso tal como aqui em baixo
corresponde no vídeo eu falei lá na
semana que vem a bola não esquece de
clicarem gostei aí também está que
amanhã ou depois de amanhã tem vídeo
novo normal aqui no canal tamo junto é
nóis e-mail e ip